[Aplausos]
[Música]
en 1945
esta red de caminos de cine
barbosa ramón martín de complican fue
más grande la chupa
amigos el día 15 de agosto de 1945 tras
haber sufrido apenas unos días antes el
único ataque con bombas nucleares de
toda la historia
tokio finalmente aceptó su rendición
[Música]
y fue en facebook
en ese momento japón era un país
derrotado su economía estaba destrozada
y los japoneses habían sufrido un daño
inimaginable no sólo se encontraban
sumidos en una pobreza extrema sino que
además habían perdido a más de tres
millones de compatriotas hermanos hijos
madres el daño de las guerras es
terrible
el caso es que siendo ésta la situación
en 1945 la pregunta que todos podemos
hacernos es cómo diantres japón logró
convertirse en poco tiempo en una de las
mayores potencias económicas del planeta
como lograron los japoneses recuperarse
tan pronto y con tanta fuerza
[Música]
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos aquí en visual político
ya hemos hablado de las diferencias
entre el modelo alemán y el modelo
japonés también os hemos contado como
japón pasó de ser un país medieval a
convertirse en una pujante nación
moderna sin embargo nos faltaba
contestar a la pregunta de cómo este
país logró en pocos años convertirse en
toda una potencia eso sí ya os adelanto
que el modelo de japón es tan particular
que vamos a necesitar más de un vídeo en
este vamos a ver algunas pinceladas pero
tranquilos porque vendrán más capítulos
la postguerra
en 1945 parecía que todo lo que se había
construido tras la restauración meiji de
1868 se había evaporado además por si
fuera poco por primera vez en toda su
historia japón tenía en su territorio
una fuerza de ocupación liderada en este
caso por los eeuu
[Música]
sin embargo queridos amigos de visual
política espera un momento porque no
todo eran tan malas noticias tal y como
vamos a ver los japoneses también tenían
tres ases bajo la manga tres
características que iban a ser capaces
de impulsar el país hasta la
estratosfera hasta convertirlo en uno de
los países más ricos del planeta incluso
a pesar de los muchos errores políticos
que tanto las fuerzas de ocupación como
las autoridades locales cometerían a lo
largo de los años
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero queréis saber cuáles fueron estas
tres claves los ingredientes principales
de la receta japonesa pues en primer
lugar una enorme capacidad y una enorme
predilección por el ahorro veréis en
general los países asiáticos y japón no
fue una excepción las familias tratan de
ahorrar hasta el último céntimo mucho
más que en prácticamente cualquier otro
lugar del mundo
explicaciones para este fenómeno hay
muchas desde que es una cuestión
cultural hasta que tiene una preferencia
temporal por el consumo menos acusada y
prefieren consumir menos hoy para
consumir mucho más mañana o que se ven
obligadas por la falta o las carencias
de los servicios públicos que en esta
parte del mundo suelen ser muy limitados
probablemente amigos todas las
explicaciones tengan un poco de verdad
pero el caso es que todo ese ahorro
luego se invierte de esta forma se crea
capital productivo que evidentemente da
lugar a mayores niveles de producción y
riqueza
es el ahorro lo que nos permite dirigir
durante un tiempo nuestros esfuerzos no
a satisfacer nuestras más inmediatas
necesidades sino a preocuparnos por
satisfacer nuestras necesidades futuras
producimos bienes de capital para que
éstos a su vez fabriquen los bienes de
consumo futuros que podamos necesitar
juan ramón rallo así que ya lo veis el
primer as en la manga que se guardó el
japón de posguerra fue precisamente una
enorme propensión al ahorro ahorro
ahorro y ahorro la segunda clave amigos
tuvo mucho que ver con la restauración
meiji de 1868
tal y como vimos en un anterior vídeo
una de las cosas primeras que se
hicieron tras este cambio de régimen fue
apostar por crear un sistema educativo
muy potente establecieron la enseñanza
primaria universal e impulsaron
universidades academias centros de
investigación etcétera etcétera de esta
forma tras la segunda guerra mundial a
pesar de su situación los japoneses eran
los trabajadores más formados de todo el
continente asiático y eso amigos es algo
que supone una enorme ventaja
competitiva
pero es que además una de las primeras
medidas que se tomaron tras la guerra
fue impulsar aún más el sistema
educativo la tercera clave bueno me
parece que todos la conocéis la enorme
capacidad para el trabajo que siempre
han tenido los japoneses siempre
dispuestos a trabajar más y más horas al
menos las anteriores generaciones y ojo
porque en algunos casos han llevado
estas cosas hasta el extremo conocéis
acaso algún otro país del mundo que
tenga una palabra para describir la
muerte por exceso de trabajo atentos el
caos y la muerte por exceso de trabajo
que en japón es un problema de salud
pública el caso amigos es que la suma de
estos tres factores hizo que japón
tuviera una enorme capacidad para crecer
recuperarse y crear muchísima riqueza
pero un momento visto esto cuáles fueron
exactamente las etapas por las que
discurrió el milagro japonés veámoslo
la gineta
no
en las etapas
[Música]
todo este proceso que vamos a ver
arranca con la ocupación de los eeuu
tras el final de la guerra veréis las
fuerzas de ocupación tuvieron dos
grandes prioridades desmilitarizar y
democratizar japonés de esta época data
por ejemplo la nueva constitución que
estableció un sistema democrático igualó
en derechos a los hombres de las mujeres
y estableció la renuncia de japón a la
guerra y a tener unas fuerzas armadas
completas además las fuerzas de
ocupación copiaron instituciones de los
eeuu y lanzaron un programa de reformas
con algunas luces y muchas sombras
creo que un día tendríamos que hablar de
lo mal que siempre han gestionado los
militares la economía de los países que
han controlado el caso es que estas
reformas tuvieron como prioridad número
uno eliminar o al menos reducir el poder
de los oligarcas que habían apoyado el
expansionismo y el militarismo japonés
para ello se aprobaron un montón de
medidas como la venta de la tierra de
los grandes latifundistas a los pequeños
campesinos se tomaron medidas para
disolver los cei batzuk que eran grandes
grupos empresariales que se dedicaban a
muchas actividades distintas pero que
estaban controlados por una única
familia se aprobó también en 1947 una
ley antimonopolio o por ejemplo se
impulsó la sindicalización de los
trabajadores todo insisto con la
intención de lograr un cambio en el
poder económico
eso sí algunas de estas medidas además
de acotar el poder de los grandes
oligarcas también tuvieron otras
consecuencias digamos bastante positivas
por ejemplo el reparto de la tierra
logró convertir en propietarios a muchos
agricultores la desaparición de muchos
de los jaivas su impulso la aparición de
muchas pequeñas y medianas empresas a
pesar de todo la recuperación fue mucho
más lenta de lo esperado sin embargo a
principios de la década de los 50 el
país tuvo por así decirlo un golpe de
suerte la guerra de korea lo convirtió
en uno de los principales proveedores de
las fuerzas aliadas disparando con ellos
sus exportaciones y también su
producción de repente las empresas
japonesas y también los políticos
descubrieron el gran mercado global para
1953 los niveles de producción ya habían
superado a los del período
inmediatamente anterior a la guerra y la
clase política tenía de nuevo una gran
prioridad en este caso impulsar el
crecimiento económico de la mano de los
negocios
[Música]
el despeje económico
amigos la década de los 50 a los 60 e
incluso los 70 fueron los años del gran
milagro los años dorados de japón un
tiempo que fue capitaneado por el
partido liberaldemócrata una formación
política que gobernó el país durante
casi 40 años ininterrumpidos hace unos
años por cierto se conoció que la cia se
gastó un pastizal en las campañas
políticas de este partido una formación
que para más señas- es el partido del
actual primer ministro shinzo abe
hoy casamos es que este partido puso en
marcha un sistema bastante peculiar
veréis por un lado impulsó políticas
para favorecer el ahorro mantuvo la
inflación bajo control
frenó el crecimiento del sector público
mantuvo los impuestos bajo siento la
acumulación de deuda vamos todo lo
contrario de lo que hacen por ejemplo
los políticos argentinos
[Música]
sin embargo espera hace un momento
porque aquí no termina todo por otro
lado a diferencia de lo ocurrido en
otros países que lograron un gran
despegue económico lo cierto es que
estos gobiernos japoneses fueron
bastante intervencionistas por ejemplo
se dedican a promocionar determinadas
industrias que ellos mismos elegían y a
las cuales ayudaban a crecer desde el
propio gobierno también impulsaron una
nueva caracterización de las empresas
nacionales supuestamente para evitar lo
que ellos consideraban una competencia
excesiva aunque no se me da a mí que
sobre todo fue una forma de ayudar a los
amiguetes la cuestión es que los
resultados fueron de bandera
a comienzos de los años 60 al primer
ministro hai hato y queda anunció un
plan para duplicar en apenas 10 años el
tamaño de la economía de japón para
llegar a cumplir la meta el país tenía
que mantener durante todo ese tiempo un
crecimiento promedio del 7 2% anual los
analistas internacionales lo
consideraron algo imposible de cumplir
diez años más tarde japón había superado
con creces el objetivo el país había
multiplicado el tamaño de su economía
por 28 gracias a que logró un
crecimiento anual medio de más del 93
por ciento
de esta forma amigos en 1973 el tamaño
de la economía japonesa se había
multiplicado por más de 5 desde 1953 es
decir en apenas 20 años por su parte el
pib per cápita se multiplicó por 4 y en
pocos años japón se convirtió en el
mayor tenedor de activos del mundo y
también el mayor proveedor de ayuda
humanitaria incluso la bolsa de tokio
logró durante un breve periodo de tiempo
superar en capitalización a la mismísima
bolsa de nueva york- a wall street pero
sabéis que amigos es aquí donde surge
una gran controversia
por un lado están los que defienden que
el espectacular crecimiento del país se
produjo a pesar de todas estas políticas
del gobierno es decir que los tres
factores que hemos visto al principio
del vídeo ahorro trabajo y formación
tuvieron tanta fuerza que lograron el
despegue de japón incluso a pesar de las
intromisiones del gobierno por otro lado
están quienes defienden que como el
gobierno mantuvo los parámetros
macroeconómicos bajo control estas
políticas públicas aceleraron el
crecimiento del país
por cierto tú a qué grupo pertenece
déjame tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta en cualquier
caso de lo que sí pocas dudas es que fue
precisamente durante esta época cuando
se consolidaron algunos de los grandes
desequilibrios que condujeron al país a
una enorme crisis de la que aún no se ha
recuperado pero de todo esto ya os
hablamos en este otro vídeo en fin
amigos si os ha resultado interesante
esta historia no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros al canal si aún no lo habéis
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
en facebook con país
[Música]